after years of development legacy
detroit automakers general motors and
ford are now entering the market for
electric trucks
these are among the first electric
vehicles from both companies and i think
the reason is it's you know this is the
most important part of their business
pick up trucks
in the race to electrify their pickups
the automakers pursued two distinct
strategies
ford decided to retrofit its existing
f-150 by adding a battery in the place
of its fossil fuel engine
gm chose a more challenging path by
designing a new battery system and
vehicles from the ground up
so how did each company race to develop
its new electric vehicles
and what sets ford and gm technology
apart in the highly competitive ev truck
race
earlier this year general motors
revealed its silverado ev a plug-in
version of gm's selling vehicle that
will go on sale in the spring of 2023
it will offer a revolutionary mix of
capability performance safety
flexibility and design gm started
very early on with sort of a ground up
approach you know they decided okay
we don't want to just do one or two evs
we tried that in the past we haven't
gotten very far we want to do a bunch of
models our clean slate approach allowed
us to create a new body architecture
which efficiently leverages the
available 24 module altium battery pack
all of gm's new evs will be built on the
company's ultim battery platform which
gm developed in-house from scratch
the electric silverado will also use the
ultim system when it is released in
spring of 2023 with prices ranging from
about forty thousand dollars to a
hundred and five thousand dollars one of
the silverado's biggest selling points
is its range thanks to gm's investment
in the ultim system a silverado is
expected to have a 400 mile range on
some models that's more than rivien's
r1t which can travel 314 miles and the
f-150 lightning which is expected to
have a range of around 300 miles i think
for years the perception's been that gm
has been ahead on their electric vehicle
strategy i mean as far back as 2017 gm
started talking about uh an all-electric
future shortly thereafter they started
you know giving us targets of how many
models you know a few dozen models by
the early 2020s you know i think all of
those things were in motion at a point
where
wall street was kind of asking for you
know where's where are all these
elements from you know where's your ev
strategy going essentially
just a day before gm unveiled its new
silverado ford announced that it was
doubling down its manufacturing goals
for its ev pickup the f-150 lightning in
response to an unexpectedly high number
of reservations
that news sent ford's stock surging on
january 4th
and help propel the automaker's market
valuation beyond that of gm for the
first time since 2016.
their stock price went up i think 11 or
12 that day which is
uh
until recently kind of unheard of for an
automaker i mean these things trade like
manufacturing stocks kind of boring and
so it was it was definitely some
gamesmanship i think on before trying to
steal a bit of a bit of gm's thunder on
its uh on its silverado truck the move
comes as the century-old rivalry between
gm and ford is moving into the electric
vehicle age
these companies they've battled in just
about every facet of the auto industry
and you know the companies don't really
like each other that much
[Music]
ford followed a different path than gm
to electrify its pickup rather than
create a new ev from the ground up
ford's strategy for the f-150 lightning
was to retrofit an existing f-150 and
turn it into an ev
this sucker's quick
the decision on ford's part was well
we want to get into market with some of
the cars that we know
our customers love we already have
strong sort of brands with the f-150
pickup truck
the mustang so let's work with that
unlike the silverado ev which looks very
different from its gas-fed predecessor
the silverado 1500 the f-150 lightning
is similar aesthetically to its
fuel-powered older sibling
and so in the case of the f-150 they
essentially modified
a gas powered pickup truck you know took
out the engine transmission
put in a big battery pack and the
electric motors and everything they
needed
engineering a wholly new electric truck
would have taken longer to develop the
retrofit enabled ford to move quickly
and beat gm to market by over a year it
also allowed ford to leverage its scale
since the lightning uses many of the
same parts as a conventional f-150
ford priced the f-150 lightning at
around forty thousand dollars for a base
model
high-end models top out in the high 90
thousands
popping the hood has been completely
redefined with the mega power front it's
got a huge front trunk called the frunk
you know and so they've made a big deal
about hey you've got lockable storage
now for the first time on a pickup truck
gm's trucks are sold under two brands
chevy and gmc
in some years gm's pickup sales under
those two brands have eclipsed total
f-series sales
but the f-150 has long been the most
popular vehicle in the country
outselling all other cars trucks and
suvs
but it remains unclear if customers will
follow the brand into its electric
future that's the big question
hanging over the whole industry right
now is all these models are coming are
there you know how much organic interest
is there among consumers
ford has been aggressively promoting the
f-150 lightning to make the case that
their new vehicle's features surpass the
gasoline model
one ad shows a family using their
lightning to provide backup power to
their house
ford said it has 200 000 lightning
reservations for context that's more
than a quarter of the number of f-series
vehicles the company sold in 2021
but these reservations are not a firm
commitment these are not binding 200 000
reservations i mean anyone can just walk
away from it but i think ford is looking
at this like this could move faster than
we thought sales for electric vehicles
rose 88 year-over-year in 2021. both
these companies realize that if we're
going to have success here we're gonna
have to carry these products that have
delivered so much value and so much
profit for these companies these big
pickup trucks you know that rivalry
seems like it's as sharp as ever as both
companies try to sort of position
themselves for that